Salvadoran President naiv bukele is on
course to win a landslide reelection on
Sunday and a lot of that has to do with
the support from Salvadorans living
abroad thanks to a new voting system
that has made the 2024 election the
first to allow internet voting from
almost anywhere in the
world we managed to reform law so they
can excise their right to vote this is a
historic election we want all
Salvadorans to continue the path we have
set for ourselves
online voting started on the 6th of
January more than 50,000 Salvadorans
cast their ballots in just the first
three days in the 2019 presidential
election less than 4,000 people living
abroad voted I'm going to be showing you
guys a way to vote many Salvadorans took
to social media to show just how easy
the process is after you follow for all
the steps we are going to vote and we're
gonna vote for noas EAS which is bu our
president of El Salvador and we're going
to vote for
him Salvadorian Community leaders in the
US say enthusiasm especially among young
Salvadorans is huge that's the thing
that I'm noticing here from the from the
younger generation uh those that are uh
were born here but that title Salvador
my goodness it is as strong as you could
possibly imagine when na buele assumed
the presidency 5 years ago he became the
youngest president president in Latin
America since then his popularity both
at home and abroad has soared to near
Rockstar status president bukela is
expected to benefit greatly from the
international vote as nearly a third of
Salvadoran citizens live outside of the
country though critics say president
bukele has violated the country's
Constitution which specifically
prohibits presidents from seeking
reelection it's a detail that most
Salvadorans don't seem too bothered by
at least for now Manu tro Al jaaz s
Salvador make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer